well one of the many concerns that
parents have when they send their kids
off to school is just to make sure that
they're safe and a charter school on the
Valley's east side is really making that
a priority but matter Academy also has a
different approach teaching kids the
skills to manage their emotions it's
located near Bonanza and Lamb and Joshua
peguero toward the public charter school
and spoke with administrators
Halo detects uh vaping smoke detects THC
smoke Robert Schmidt head of security at
matter Academy is showing us new
technology at middle and high school
bathrooms so if someone wants to come in
here and say they use the vaping event
and it went off it would have actually
come my phone would tell me what
bathroom it was in I first met Schmidt
at the National Response conference last
week at the Flamingo Hotel he tells us
he's brought back some of that knowledge
which included paying attention to a
child's Behavior once the weapon the gun
the person is on your property it's
almost too late what did we do before
that before that action came this here
is one of only two check-ins that they
have a matter Academy any person that
wants to get in the building has to
check in on one of these two individuals
and the school as another precaution has
security cameras all over the lead
principal of matter Academy is Renee
Fairless she spent more than 20 years in
the Clark County School District
including being a principal at Sunrise
Mountain High School one of our big
focus is to build the relationship if
you build the relationship with the
student you not only learn more about
that student but you also learn more
about what that student's capable of
doing matter Academy has an enrollment
of 4 000 students from kindergarten to
12th grade Fairless says it's important
to learn the students home life to make
a difference in 4 000 students on the
east side of Las Vegas it it seems like
a big task but one that certainly can
make a huge difference
matter Academy also has a monitoring
system they call it securely on all
computers it looks into what kids are
searching online and whether
administrators need to follow up on what
they're searching